c'est un message clair que ces femmes
ont lancé à l'unisson la violence faite
aux femmes doit cesser je suis chez nous
puis-je en pleurs quand je vois qu'il y
a des féminités d'ailleurs même ici au
Québec il y en a et la violence
conjugale ça le beaucoup aussi de
répercussions sur les enfants on les
oublie des fois mais il faut partir de
la famille puis vivre ça aussi avec les
femmes même après 6 ans que j'ai je me
suis dit
je prends toujours des mesures de
sécurité parce que on sait jamais
l'actualité des derniers jours là une
fois de plus démontré lundi soir un père
de famille de Laval aurait tué ses deux
enfants il aurait agressé sa femme puis
deux jours plus tard une femme de 90 ans
aurait été tué par son conjoint à
Vaudreuil d'Orion chaque fois qu'il y a
quelque chose comme ça c'est ça touche
tout le monde mais moi ça me touche
particulièrement c'est que Christine
Giroud connaît trop bien les
conséquences de la violence conjugale et
la quitter son ex-conjoint mais chaque
fois qu'il sort de guérison il la
retrouve la violence conjugale ça va
loin c'est
c'est extrême c'est quand même une femme
à tous les deux jours et demi qui est
tué par son conjoint ou son ex-conjoint
Manon monastère constate l'escalade de
violence depuis la pandémie plusieurs
maisons d'hébergement pour femme de la
province sont remplis à pleine capacité
et aux nombreux féminicides s'ajoutent
les tentatives de meurtre c'est quand
même 200 femmes qui nous ont dit
qu'elles avaient été victimes d'une
tentative de meurtre mais qui savait pas
été rapporté à la police il souligne la
création du tribunal spécialisé en
matière de violence sexuelle et
conjugales il a mis sur pied des
bracelets anti rapprochement mais selon
elle il est impératif de pousser la
concertation plus loin
on travaille pas un contre l'autre on
travaille ensemble il faut que les
hommes fassent passer la solution je
pense c'était le message que j'avais
passé aujourd'hui mais on est très
conscient c'est pas terminé je lui ai
donné ma voix à toutes celles qui se
sont éteints Christine Giroud qui
organisait cette marche combien
continuer une marteler son message je
trouve qu'on en parle seulement quand
c'est médiatisé après on en parle plus
on s'attende dans l'oubli jusqu'ici en
2022 12 femmes sont mortes aux mains
d'un conjoint ou d'un ex-conjoint
violent et chaque féminicide en étant de
trop ici qui me permettra au Canada
Montréal